right so there's a bunch of different
frameworks out there for how to achieve
your goals but one really simple one
that i use all the time is the idea of
simplicity and clarity in setting a goal
and this is what i'm discussing with my
friend and life coach and business coach
and author of the unfair advantage
husson cooper in this episode of the
deep dive snippet and we're talking
about how to use this framework for goal
setting in the context of me writing my
book but to be honest you can apply it
to basically any goal that you're
working on um so i'm i was working on a
draft of chapter one this morning which
is all about like why you shouldn't
really set hard goals and you should
actually focus on setting easy goals
and that's sort of the
sort of somewhat counter-narrative
argument i'm trying to make that screw
smart goals focus on goals that are
within your control and uh once you've
got a goal then thinking think of it
purely as a destination and then just
completely forget about it because at
that point fixating on it or even
thinking about it at all is at least for
me like not a very helpful thing
and it's how and it should be like you
know oh i imagine the the treasure at
the end of the rainbow and then that
will motivate you to do the thing but at
least for me i find that imagining the
treasure at the end of the rainbow does
not at all motivate me to do the thing
and instead focusing on the bits that i
can control focusing on the journey
focusing on okay my only task right now
is to just
write one really shitty first draft of
this next of this chapter i'm on 2700
words cool let's just keep on going and
then any time i think oh but like this
sounds bad or oh but i should probably
edit it oh here or oh but like i i think
nope stay on task enjoy the journey i've
got my music in the background i've got
my coffee i've got my oat milk whatever
and i'm just like banging stuff out
speed speed running writing the first
chapter oh cool um and that seems to be
working
but i often find myself like
i think one of the issues with these
sorts of non-fiction books is that
really
it's not really about what's true it is
about what's useful
i think in a self-help book like this
like you know james clear you know
atomic habits the four things that make
a habit stick it may not matter that
this mental model is 100 true yeah but
if it's a useful way of modeling the
information and it's true enough that
people can use it and apply it to their
lives
you know similar to left brain right
brain analogy like
that's not actually how the brain works
like oh right brain is creative and left
brain is not but like
just having that model is still somewhat
useful where you think you know if
someone said it describes themselves as
a more like right brain kind of person
or if someone says oh i'm really high on
trait extroversion like you know the
ocean personality traits it's not
actually how the brain works it's just a
model that we've taken to put on top of
it to kind of simplify things and as
long as it's useful it's all good but at
the same time i i keep on like poking
holes in my own argument where i'm like
yeah but you know you know my point is
that for me setting more achievable and
easier goals is better than setting
harder goals but also if you look at the
evidence actually there's a bunch of
evidence that setting challenging goals
is better than setting easy goals and
like what the hell how do you oh and i
keep on kind of second guessing and
guessing myself how do you how do you
deal with that right
yeah this is important and i think what
you're doing is you're thinking on paper
it's like what i said about coaching
like i said that
one of the biggest takeaways is you
don't know what you think until you hear
yourself say it
and it's similarly with writing that's
why writing's are valuable that's why
journaling is sort of a good analog to
coaching if specifically if you follow a
good structure it's you're figuring out
what you think by writing it down
that's what's happening there
and
i'm impressed that you're you're
disciplined enough to not edit as you
write because i still ended up doing
that quite a bit but as much the more i
stayed away from it the better it was um
yes so going back to the whole idea of
mental models i think this is huge and i
talk about that in the book i was like
so here so why did i went meta and said
okay look there's two
two models extreme models one is success
is all luck and the other success is all
hard work and merited and earned and
success if it's all fate and luck and
unearned that's the other one the truth
is in the middle and then i talked about
this kind of tension between the two so
that's one approach is you could
describe it as a tension and you could
talk about how yes you could do hard
goals but you can also do easy goals and
here's how to think about it
but yeah the whole thing about mental
models is fascinating that's one thing
that i got out of economics is is in
economics it's too complicated just like
the human body it's way too complicated
any guru out there telling you well this
is to burn fat and this one's just
bloody may turn your body alkaline or
some [ __ ] like that yeah it's all
oversimplified for the most part
nonsense for the most part even when
they sound like they're using scientific
language and they're saying insulin this
and ghrelin and leptin and all this
stuff it's like okay yeah but it's
actually super super super complicated
and this is an oversimplification but
you know what the patients whose doctors
tell them well you know the saturated
fat that you're eating is just firing up
and clogging your arteries that's not
actually how it works but if it's a
simple model for them to use and if
saturated fats were actually bad which
is very
it's a whole other kettle fish but the
point is that you want to help people to
change their behavior and transform so
this goes back to the online course
something so you could be a youtuber and
you can be an educational youtuber
obviously you could do comedy you could
do whatever you could do drama the point
is to be an educational youtuber is a
whole category and you could then teach
physics and maths but then there's
another sub segment of educational which
i said transformational creator so
you're helping people to transform and
that's what you're doing with your book
you're helping people transform what is
that that's mindset and behavior change
ultimately it's behavior change really
because that will also change the
mindset and the identity and all of that
stuff so
for behavior change how do you motivate
people to change their behavior you
oversimplify
that's one thing and then you make power
you empower and oversimplify to give
them clarity to be like okay simple i
just need to do this yeah
um
now that's an overly simplistic
you know self-help book which does that
it's kind of too can be too far so you
might want to make it deeper and talk
about how the people go back and forth
but here's what's worked for me and
here's what i want to do so the the
phrase i always like to go back to is
the map is not the terrain
or the map is not the territory
so whatever you're mapping is not going
to be the actual thing otherwise it's a
useless map imagine you had a one-to-one
map that had every single detail that's
not useful map so what you're trying to
do is you're mapping reality and you're
saying okay here's one way here's our
approach is set easy goals as you call
it and basically are you saying process
oriented goals in that sense uh yeah
more or less yeah so what we what you
have to do is set your own glossary and
start to define your own terms and then
within your own universe and what makes
sense to others because one of the
things is uh initially when we're using
the word productivity and you say well
productivity isn't just about output
over time and you had a great podcast
episode with on jaded jade and you were
discussing that and
well i mean you have to realize that
you're taking liberties with the word
productivity yeah to include
um like intentionality and meaning and
like enjoyment and joy and all that jazz
which wouldn't traditionally be
in a technical dictionary definition of
progress and therefore you could say
let's redefine productivity to mean this
yeah and then i can do what i want
because i know you've laid out mine
you've redefined it got it hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day